welcome back to new rock stars i'm
philip molina and here's the question
did mephisto ever show up anywhere in
2021 and if not is eric voss ready to
make a public apology well we're about
to go because it's our annual edition of
what we got wrong say it with me
everybody yeah
performance review for eric boss right
here right now in the comment section um
let us know how much we should dock his
pay or supplement or
uh also empty should have been part of
this too this is he had to eat smart
take vacation during your performance
review yeah exactly
it has been it has been an annual
tradition uh we do this every year when
things wrap up and um in our even this
scary pocket reality that we're in right
now uh it's still nice to look back at
our past year and we deal with some
self-effacing humor here and eric
probably will go into a defensive rage
i'm sure about a number of these things
uh but eric does a lot of uh
off-the-mark theories and i i like that
he has to own up to them sometimes the
fact that we review that that hopefully
gives you a little bit of uh excitement
whenever you hear an eric boss theory it
means he's gonna answer for it if he's
wrong even putting myself at the risk of
uh the people who hate me on twitter who
are gonna be watching this episode uh
clipping out little receipts that they
will use to try to cancel me i am
braving the slings and arrows of
outrageous fortune bring him on last
time we did this uh it was uh from 2020
going into 2021 and you know there was a
a a little pandemic that made it so that
all the theories were wrong about every
movies almost didn't happen you got off
light that year but now as the person
responsible for continuing the pandemic
i think that you know that we can't use
that excuse this time so
2021 how do you feel you did overall a
plus no notes goodbye everybody i get to
keep my job bye-bye
look i started off this year feeling
like i should never pitch a theory again
um but as the year went on i got some
calls surprisingly right so i feel like
i ended the year in a much better place
than i thought i was i would say
somewhere like i don't know somewhere in
the 70 percentile which is unacceptable
in the vos house growing up um but you
know with my kids as long as they don't
drop out of school uh they're good in my
book they're still in the will 70
percentile
as a company i don't know i might be
with the voss family i have a call with
your parents after this every year and
okay i don't know if they'll enjoy that
let me know how they're doing they don't
pick up the phone when they call it
well they changed their number years ago
just a quick reminder if you like what
we do at the rock stars the best way to
support us is with our merch new
rockstarsmerch.com we have all kinds of
uh great shirts going on inspired by all
the stuff that we we love right now i
know eric
loves his strange entanglement shirt i
love the trusted bro shirt because uh i
just love the bros from hawkeye uh so
much uh and then we have a new boba fett
hunter design that actually uh a little
little easter egg there just inspired by
some banksy artwork uh just for for
those of you that are interested in that
kind of thing again this new rockstars
merch.com okay
let's get started with what we
this is the year of mephisto eric voss
we're starting with it you knew
you knew that this would be
the
thing that like come on okay
i feel like you've been waiting for this
moment
all year
to answer to the new rockstars audience
and honestly
to the world
what went wrong there methystose
mephisto mephisto i'm going down with
the ship agatha's husband ralph is
mephisto mephisto methystos mephisto
mephisto mebisto mepisto mephisto
mephisto mephisto
mephisto methysto methystomophisto
methysto the fisto pistol who's the real
mepisto or what went right there don't
because i don't don't give us hope
so here's what i will say about mephisto
gate it's not a gate it's a door it's a
portal and he's standing on the other
side of it waving at you with a string
of grapes that are the sweetest tasting
grapes if you're willing to take a a
taste of them i um i did go hard on the
mephisto theories for one division now
everyone thinks that i predict mephisto
and everything after one division i
cooled it on mephisto okay even with
multiverse of madness i i've said
maybe but there's probably other stuff
going on there what was really
embarrassing about mephisto is like not
only did he not show up anywhere in one
division in interviews weeks after jack
schaefer was like yeah i had no idea who
mephisto was when i started working on
the series she
she hadn't read the west coast avengers
comics room fist was part of it yeah she
kept calling me hysto yeah they should
not ever admit in interviews that they
didn't read the comics that it was based
on just act like you did because fans
are like what you didn't read the comics
yeah philip you remember being there
when one division was happening there
was that moment in episode seven because
up until that point everyone thought
mephisto was going to be on this show
like we all saw the same evidence we saw
the devils in the details we saw unleash
hell demon spawn we saw the parallels
with the west coast avenger comics we
heard paul bettany saying multiple
interviews that some huge cameo was
coming at the end of the cameo season
oh a major cameo an act i've always
wanted to work with um and then uh
episode seven happens and they say it
was agatha all along and then i'm like
nope was it the sag though there's
someone else
double or nothing
yeah i doubled down so hard and i think
like
you know when i look back on it i don't
want to use any of the evidence as
excuses um because like
i was the guy
who pointed to a lot of random stuff
saying oh it's mephisto confirmed like i
did point to the hexagonal shape of the
frames in hayward's office i pointed to
every puff of red smoke i never said the
butterfly yeah yeah i pointed to quite a
few clues and i think the most uh
egregious one philip remember this how
like we said that there was a blur a
gray blur in a mirror
uh that looks like a hand that was
reaching out toward uh wanda when peter
shows up yeah
yeah we made that the thumbnail i still
can't really explain what that blur is
but the fact that i was able to like
connect that to the people just though
like it's
uh it was a bit of a it was definitely a
stretch i thought like we had grown as
much as we're ever going to grow
everyone who thought we existed or
thought would look for us had already
found us but no that was a random huge
month for us like we got 120 000
subscribers in a month none of us
expected that all that attention
suddenly we were in a spotlight as like
the the tip of the spear for these
theories that everyone else was and
while everyone else abandoned ship after
act all along i was like nope i'm still
on the train and then so i think a lot
of these newcomers put all my
credibility on whether or not mephisto
was going to be in the show and when he
wasn't they're all like what an idiot i
don't trust this guy even though i feel
like i've made way worse calls than
mephisto before on this channel i mean
you know we've done this every year it's
a really stupid theory
i'm grateful this happened i think
mephisto represents something that is
honestly a good thing for new rock stars
i like having a north star even if that
north star rather than it being god for
most people on planet earth for me it's
madisto the devil because it keeps us
like looking around every corner it
keeps the hunt alive and it keeps the
blood pumping i love it i'm proud of the
work we did no apologies uh yeah well
you sound downright uh engorged about it
but
i
will say
that you
had
a lot of clues
um that were working toward your theory
and that
is different than other times when
you've been off the mark right i still
my favorite is still always gonna be cap
eight the soul stone
i don't think that all right
that's my thing that's what blew my mind
about mephisto is like the fact that
people still like they were saying that
as a scarlet letter i'm like if you were
around with new rockstars in 2018 i was
the guy who said that cap ate the soul
stone at some point like how am i not
made fun of for that but because the
clues on that were like bad color
correcting but this one they really were
not only giving lots of clues but also
it's in the comics you you weren't you
weren't like making up th this concept
you literally said mephisto is your god
i wonder if you
can see
that you were in a way not only in a
cult
but a cult leader you were kind of
brainwashed and into like confirming
your own beliefs
it's kind of like if uh uh l ron hubbard
believes his own [ __ ] or believed i
think every cult leader does i mean
because i'd rather i think it's the
power of magical thinking right like you
we all create our own little
sub-realities or in pocket realities in
a way this is true for wanda maximoff
right like this she created a pocket
reality based off her own wish
fulfillment of the way she wanted her
life to be and i like to live in a world
where there are little
demons that are
you know whispering to us from the
shadows that we have to say not today
mephisto and we have to know when to
ignore them and when to follow them down
the rabbit hole and in the world of
fandom only in the world of fandom not
in the real world but in the world of
fandom it's it's really fun to watch
these shows that way to be uh to be on
the hunt for what kind of you know
machiavellian evil could be pulling the
strings of everything and and with like
weirdly with kang with kingpin that
thinking worked out okay well we'll get
to what you got right uh later in the
redemption
zone uh but i'll say
like are you sure that that it you can
you have that solid grip on reality
where you're like
oh it's only in the shows that i do this
or whatever but i mean like there's no
way that your brain isn't looking for
clues just you have the illuminati in
real life or lizard people
you know here's an example of conspiracy
theory um so you know my dog darla i
think she's a sweetie i love darla so
much but uh she does not like strangers
who come to the house and she like barks
and snaps at them when we first met her
she was so docile around us like she
could sit in my lap and let me pet her
and i have a conspiracy theory that
kelly's like you're crazy that the
foster parents we got her from uh got
darla from um drugged her and that's the
reason why darla was so sweet around
this is that she was sedated a little
bit and kelly's like i mean eric you've
been you've been focusing too much on me
fisto episode is not applied that's
famously how orphanages work they give
all the kids they line them all up and
they all do a spoonful of diamond tap
just get the kids just like loose to be
like very like chill with like the
prospective parents or whatever just
like very authentic no nerves or
whatever
i would not be surprised if that's a if
that's what uh happened uh eric um final
uh uh thing on mephisto if uh you could
take it back would you
never
no i would have gone harder
yeah even larger uh
tattoo over your butt
moving on
we accept mephisto we own mephisto
uh but
that's not exactly where the mephisto
story ends
because oh yeah a trailer came out uh
for uh spider-man and no way home eric
along with many people but eric
definitely uh again tip of the spear
here uh of the crazy spear uh was like
doctor strange is behaving awfully
strange to be fair there was a wink and
we all know that what winks mean
perverts but
he and then they did remove it from from
the actual film once it came out you had
a couple of theories i know one of them
was could he be mephisto in disguise but
also that another one was that perhaps
he's under the spell of the scarlet
witch and we now look at this strange
who's just warm and cozy by a fireplace
your friendly neighborhood strange like
he's waving at you from across the
picket fence in west view sheltering in
place with witch's brew and witchy winks
who deceives and sends our most trusted
sorcerer packing i don't think it's that
insane to conclude that the scarlet
witch is destined succession of the
sorcerer's supreme and proven mastery of
his iconic spell reclaiming his theme
music is all evidence pointing to doctor
strange being the latest puppet under
wanda maximoff's spell gladly using
peter parker's request to rewrite
reality as a pretext to collide the
multiverse in pursuit of reality where
her children exist uh eric
he was just
all benny comfy batch like he was just
normal
doctor strange how will you answer for
your sins
um i will say that uh i was very wary of
mephisto from that devil and disguised
poster from the first trailer and right
away i said not today mephisto i don't
care how many parallels there were two
one more day but yeah i did go pretty
hard on this theory that there were
flames that popped up right yeah yeah
yeah um i really thought that uh knowing
that scarlet witch was going to show up
in multiverse madness i thought that his
weird behavior uh there's definitely
some evidence there and i was wrong
wrong
i was totally wrong on the scarlet witch
puppeting um strange under her spell
theory but here's what i'll say for all
these theories then you know
it could still be true in multiverse of
madness we could say no it's not true
because in the trailer
she's like what are you doing here
doctor strange so um yeah i i i
got a little creative with that one but
isn't it cooler if she was controlling
him i think that's my is it or is it
like like more interest is it more
interesting for the character that he
upon his own agency is making these
radical choices yeah i guess you're
right
it makes her a more badass villain if
she is controlled it makes her cooler
definitely yeah and it would also be the
return of you know not just um what we
saw in one division but just really that
classic scarlet witch how we first met
her of the little uh brain mist that she
would do with her red goo and you know
uh mind control a lot she you know
doesn't do it on a one-to-one level as
much uh these days but having seen the
film now do you think that doctor
strange was behaving in a way consistent
with this character or do you think that
that was still weird that he helped
peter now that you have the full context
they took out the wink from the movie i
as i've seen it like five times at this
point i don't think it was uh as much
out of character as it seemed from the
trailer because he is a risk taker the
fact that um he was able to get um
wong's permission sort of like wong said
leave me out of this it seemed a little
less
you know he did see his heart kind of
melted when peter said i'm sorry for
wasting your time like the the way the
acting played out it didn't seem that
out of character um i i don't have that
much of a problem with the way doctor
strange was depicted my only issue is
that he was just basically strung up in
the grand canyon for half the movie when
the most interesting stuff happened i i
want to touch on another theory you got
dead wrong wrong
uh really quick on spiderman no way home
i don't think it's a big deal one but i
do want to know that i want you to know
that we count all of these there was a
moment tom holland uh where did he first
meets uh doc
tom hollands by peter parker
is wearing the same thing that toby toby
maguire's uh peter parker wore uh and
you had a theory that that was because
it was like through the perception of
doc ock and because uh or maybe that
toby's soul was inside of tom's body
that's why doc ock recognizes him but
that would also be why this peter looks
so confused standing next to this
woman's car window as if seconds earlier
he was staring at his own reflection and
confused why it looked like tom holland
that could also explain why this peter
appears in the toby outfit and why peter
in this same outfit looks even more
confused in that murky dungeon or so and
it was just like no they were just it
was just similar outfits uh i just want
you to know that we uh we clocked that
one
you know we should do a whole other
video that just looks at like the big
red herring goose chases
in these trailers that come out like
when we get these details that feel like
they're bombshells that later when the
movie comes out we're like oh that
wasn't that that big of a deal just an
interesting parallel you know
coincidence but
um when we see these things it feels so
like smoking gun right yeah like i think
the more interesting detail about that
is how wrinkled his suit was like poor
peter parker probably stuffed that in
his backpack and he's like the typical
college kid going to a college interview
and he's just got the most wrinkled tie
this wrinkled suit yeah but
yeah that one uh real quick i mostly i'm
mostly chuckling to myself at the image
of a red herring chasing a goose
like these two of those birds
[Music]
crazy birds uh uh speaking of uh uh
crazy birds uh as a british uh person
would say uh the black widow uh film
came out this year i don't mean that
she's crazy i mean that they were all
mind controlled and uh
there were a lot of theories that um you
had and they were wrong
eric they were wrong
oh god it brings me a little bit of joy
they're uh the two that that um come to
mind well or maybe even let's say the
three that come to mind one is that and
i remember the thumbnail too um that the
pym particles would be an is a important
plot device in the black widow films
because there was a red vial but right
before she died natasha still possessed
one unused pym particle during that fall
so let's just say that in those brief
seconds as she fell natasha gets an idea
now she has accepted her fate she's
ready to trade her soul for the soul
stone but she still has this unused pen
particle in her pocket and she thinks oh
the things i still could do with smack
too late she hits the ground but let's
say back during the fall natasha
realizes that she has some unfinished
business and now she actually has a way
to clear some of the red in her ledger
uh we later learned obviously that that
uh that that was a lie so that was a lie
and then also uh that the movie would
feature um natasha uh romanov coming
back
and being resurrected uh somehow through
some sort of adjustment of the timeline
because
you just i think uh wish fulfillment or
something you wanted you wanted that to
happen and then third of course is just
that um that they would do a face swap
uh face transplant style uh and just
gave that away right there uh in the uh
uh trailers yeah just answer to all of
us they did do a face swap it was not a
surgical
uh nick cage john travolta face-off but
they did have masks where they traded
identities it just didn't involve yelena
it was natasha and me that is not what
you meant you meant you did some
surgical crazy replacement
no that is not that crazy they did the
mission impossible
you meant like that they would hide the
seams of the scars
on florence pugh's face with now like
well the body is florence pugh who's
dead and then broken
completely wrong wrong here's the deal i
uh i got the i found the detail of the
marker line around her face i was able
to correctly predict that a face swap
did happen now did it mean that that
lying around her face led to a face swap
no it didn't i got that part of it wrong
but if like you just take out the full
middle the the ending and the beginning
are right but you know they weren't pin
particles that one was just stupid
that was just like an example of like
come on marvel differentiate your
production design a little bit why did
you have to have red vials for you so
many colors it's gonna be the ether in
there like they're they're they're
running not options i will say that pin
particles showing up in a random kind of
low-key uh avenger uh story apparently
not that far-fetched significant the
usage of pimp articles in hawkeye now
you also this one is is fair i think
that you got this very wrong in black
widow but uh just the identity of
taskmaster you and everyone on on the
channel all kinds of theories about who
taskmaster would be yeah for sure for
sure um i i did not uh think that it
would be drakov's daughter i really
thought it was okay
here's where i won't hold that against
you i don't know that it still won't be
a new version of taskmaster that we
still get in the future just saying
because like the concept of being
taskmaster i think that isn't
necessarily exclusive to one character
uh speaking of uh these um
these characters that are pulling
strings the big reveal
uh those big moments uh you got another
one in falcon winter soldier uh and this
one i'm just gonna straight up admit
i wish you were right i really wish you
were right the identity of the power
broker
you thought so it turned out to be
sharon carter you thought it was gonna
be
the mandarin now marvel dropped this
trailer the same week of the finale of
the falcon in the winter soldier which
has been teasing a mysterious power
broker operating out of majorport in
southeast asia whom i have been
theorizing in many videos could be
connected to the 10 rings maybe even the
mandarin himself and it's not like i've
ever been wrong about a marvel series
finale before
which would have been so much cooler
which would have like tied all of like
that criminal underworld together
especially the version that we were
seeing was so
uh similar uh to the ten rings like
the vibes were kind of like this this
quasi-futuristic eastern gang style like
that would have been
oh perfect uh but no it was sharon
carter
which um
and i thought with people on twitter
against it being sharon carter i went
hard against sharon carter for power
broker i think sharon carter's the prowl
broker what do you think
no
i do but i think she could be connected
to the power but we talked about this a
bit in the inside marvel after show i i
think she's got a weird story that she
needs to yeah
she's weirdly powerful it's weird that
she has this uh whole art collection now
and that's the world that she lives in
when she could just live low profile off
the grid to be fair you go hard on a lot
of people on twitter
yeah that's my new year's resolution to
stop going so hard on twitter but you're
right yeah i think the show would have
been better if the power broker was win
woo from from shangchi but and i
remember like i really should own this
one because uh i like my reasoning was
that the shanghi trailer dropped the
week before the finale of falcon winter
soldier so i said that's why they they
wanted us to remind us that when woo
existed like it was so stupid it was
just it was on singapore's birthday no
but they do that right like hawkeye had
that with no way home with the
simultaneously they did that's what's so
hard about this sometimes your reasoning
is proven right in other places but
again somewhere else you were wrong
you falcon winner soldier you also said
it would tell us what happened to old
man steve rogers uh and uh that new
shield with the little panels uh that
maybe we're gonna open
i believe this new shield was given to
cap by wakanda in an alternate timeline
and it's composed of a new form of
vibranium a new alloy that we will be
calling proto-adamantium and it has
secret detachable parts projectiles and
properties that are only activated when
wielded by its rightful owner no no we
didn't get any of the new shield uh
information and old man steve rogers is
as far as we know still on that bench
it's on a bench on the moon who knows
again the show would have been better
had they answered that question i
understand that they can only do so much
on these disney plus shows they have to
stay focused on their characters on
their arcs they can't just like answer
all the big burning questions throughout
the mcu but like feige come on they're
using that shield give us some answers
come on
baby oh speaking of a thing that feige
could have done and given us would have
been some mutants
which you theorized speaking of chongqi
would be in a fighting tournament in
madripore other mutants that marvel
wants to tie in this universe because
really the exciting element about these
tournament participants isn't the
character names themselves it's the
section of the marvel world that they
come from and what that tells us about
where the mcu will expand next like for
example the mutants omega red and whiz
kid tell us that marvel might be
implying mutants already exist in this
universe and we're about to meet a lot
more of them that was wrong you're wrong
dead wrong uh
it could have been cool for sure we
definitely could have gotten even i'd be
down for more uh tournament um
a whole tournament maybe uh disney plus
series or something could be very very
great but chunky was great so i i don't
hold uh that against it i hold it
against you for teasing that you thought
since we're right there ready to show up
you do it again and again i mean at this
point should we are you going to keep
theorizing how soon mutants are going to
come in are you just going to kind of
yeah i honestly yeah i pushed hard on
inside marvel last episode that uh
multiverse of madness has to has to
introduce mutants in the mcu i mean i
think my bigger issue with shanghi is uh
i which i really really like that movie
i'm with you i don't want to fault the
movie too much that and mortal kombat
were two movies heading into 2021 that i
thought were both gonna be fighting
tournament movies and neither of them
had fighting tournaments they they
briefly showed people sparring but they
had no brackets you know at any point in
either of those movies and i like my
brackets i want the brackets no
parentheses brackets so i
with when i got in that bracket mindset
i'm like well who do we fill in this
bracket well we gotta have a mutant in
there so
yeah no mutants
yeah
no i mean they're definitely gonna have
them we bought fox just for a
mole man is that a fox character i think
it might be speaking of uh powerful old
men classic loki let's go move on to
loki for a second uh he has that amazing
uh death has that uh that richard e
grant performance is just like such a
great way to send out the character and
you said
he's not gone you see this floating
debris eric said that that was classic
loki in disguise
and he's just he's waiting for a moment
like ha ha
i'm back
notice as they approach that castle a
piece of debris floats up now at first i
thought this could have been a ship but
even if it is just debris classic loki
just confirmed that floating debris can
sometimes be a loki in disguise after he
fakes his death classic loki for some
reason passed up mobius's offer to leave
the void and then he stayed and showed
off an insane level of sorcery sorcery
that he spent who knows how long
refining and then could have faked his
death in that moment and then lured
these variants to his castle where he
reveals himself as he who remains an
original loki who survived and built the
timekeepers and the tva in order to
control the multiverse with this
ultimate illusion yeah no he was
with loki i got a lot right about loki
so people kind of overlooked this this
call but like i think my episode five
breakdown i did end with a hard pitch
that uh classic loki was not dead i
think i was afraid that was kind of like
my backup option in case it wasn't kang
and then ended up being kang who was
like my number one pick of who was
probably in that citadel that episode i
was so drunk on the reveal richard grant
had that monologue that confirmed a
theory i had back in 2018 that in one of
these past episodes i had to apologize
for that loki faked his death by being
debris floating behind thanos and
infinity war which seemed so stupid
after uh you know months after but then
he said that in his timeline that is
exactly what he did it's like they
watched our video and they confirmed
that theory so i was like
i am unstoppable so i went hard on that
[ __ ] at the end of that breakdown ended
up not being correct or we will see
i don't know
no it's just not correct while we're on
another disney plus show uh just real
quick on what if i actually think you
know what if it's such a weird property
that i was down to go into all kinds of
weird um theories but there was one that
you tease and again wrong
[Music]
but it was that the zombie virus
uh was actually caused by uh that uh
infectious disease that was stolen in
the beginning of civil war and just that
idea of like teasing it and like that
all branch timeline i thought that would
have been uh real cool um but you were
still wrong so you still uh lose um ten
percent of your pay for it but you know
instead it came from the quantum realm
from nowhere and we have no idea why
that one is uh excusable i would say but
you know what's not excusable again the
mutants you said that the eternals were
gonna bring mutants into the mcu again
and assuming we actually get to see the
creation process of the eternals by the
celestials it seems likely the origins
of humankind and mutant kind will also
be explored since the history of all of
these is connected in marvel lore back
to the celestials the dna imagery in the
eternals trailer might be pointing to
this genetic history they should have
they should have done it they were
already introducing the eternals
and and really like a serious version of
celestials so you're like and also
mutants you thought that's how they were
gonna do it i think they should have i
think we should have gotten a tease of
uh an apocalypse apocalypse yeah they
decided to do several other things in
eternals
yeah uh a room uh with a bunch of funny
toys in it stop teasing me that we we're
getting mutants soon i'm hearing you
want to hear more mutant theories okay
got it um you also had a lot of theories
recently but these are kind of vacant of
just about uh who the new owners of the
avengers tower uh are i you you said in
hawkeye they were they're gonna tell us
didn't know way home they were gonna
tell us now in the skyline you can make
out the tower that was once avengers
tower which was recently remodeled to be
given an atrium with a nearby sign on
the ground level reading we are so
excited to show you what comes next with
the numbers 1 2 3 and
possibly a hint to the fantastic four
now the popular theory is that the
building could become reed richard's
baxter building and now that spider-man
director john watts is directing the
fantastic four film for marvel studios
as well i think that's a strong
possibility uh we don't know and uh we
still don't know and i really i screwed
up a detail in the hawkeye finale where
i pointed to a building that should i
can't remember that anymore but there is
a skyscraper in the middle of manhattan
and i'm like that skyscraper doesn't
exist in the real world and everyone in
new york is like what are you talking
about people tweeted at you
so definitely blew that call i don't
think this tower exists in real life and
yes it is interesting that it is masked
by steam here this is roughly where
avengers tower used to be located
there's a uh there was one die-hard fan
in the building having like an
existential crisis
[Laughter]
legitimately though like there are
probably some people that watch
your your videos and think like this guy
knows what he's talking about and you
would say like this essential this huge
skyscraper that they see every day
you're like that's not real
you're
one last thing i want to rub your face
in um this one was weird because okay it
is mcu related but it leaves the mcu and
it goes to a film called free guy
uh with uh my my one of my big celebrity
crushes ryan reynolds is uh he
is playing a character that in some ways
could be considered an avatar like you
know uh we could plug in different roles
there and you had this idea that he was
actually going to be revealed to be
deadpool and deadpool is almost like
using the concept of free guy as like a
meta way to bridge his way into the mcu
which was such a big swing a big stupid
swing like you're not even on the field
but you're like in like the locker room
but you just like gave it your all and
just like smashed up a display case uh
and so i respected the force of the
swing the ingenuity the creativity uh
but wow
that's one of the biggest uh plops i
think of your your national theory you
know i felt when i first pitched it and
one of our early free guide trailer
breakdowns i was like this is kind of a
stretch but then they did a promo with
deadpool and korg remember that for free
guy and i was like whoa is this
happening like disney
put korg in a commercial with deadpool
like is this our first deadpool
crossover to the mcu i got super excited
for it um but no i think a lot of my
theories were tied in with noob master
69 like we never figured out who the
master 69 was in fortnite and then they
revealed it as dc pearson from that one
xbox commercial with us anthony mackie
so um yeah yeah that one was a real
silly one
yeah
the uh apple store employee from winter
soldier was the aaron apple store aaron
as always um you know when you take a
dog and you rub their nose and in their
mess then you walk them you shouldn't do
that
you give them some treats to confuse
them
that's what i i would like to do for you
now i want to reward you uh for some uh
uh real great um wins you got this year
okay uh one you said that um kovid was
only gonna get worse and you were gonna
see to it
i did say that you you nailed it
um
uh
no you uh you got a lot of spider-man no
way home right almost too much uh one of
the big ones was the um the fact that
the beginning of of bridging the
multiverse across other universes
including like cinematic uh universes uh
what happened in this movie we're gonna
see a toby maguire peter parker cameo in
there and we are going to see an andrew
garfield and that it would also lead to
an upcoming crisis with scarlet witch
yeah i think a lot of people like some
of that's really old too right like
years ago you were talking about some of
this yeah i think that's the difference
there it's like
everyone assumed that toby and andrew
would show up like you know uh
several months out i went back and forth
on how likely that was but i i do
remember like two years before the movie
came out i did make a move i did make a
video i'm like is toby gonna come back
in the next spider-man movie morbius is
set in an alternate universe in the vast
spidey verse perhaps the reason raimi
was hired to direct multiverse madness
is because marvel wanted his oversight
as they attempt to establish a
live-action multiverse that can bridge
over to sony spider-verse in the future
in retcon all past spider-man films like
the andrew garfield era and sam raimi's
toby maguire spider-man as just
alternate realities within this shared
multiverse just as one of these [ __ ]
theories forgot about it and then at
some point resented at the conspiracy
theories that were then forming as a
result of my speculation and then uh to
see toby mcguire walk that portal like
me pre covid was like
ah
he got one
yeah well you actually got a couple
right uh because you also just the the
in that lead up where you have andrew
garfield out there acting his ass off
saying i'm not in it it's a shop
um
and uh and then that trailer comes out
and
uh we see tom hall and spider-man
fighting uh the sinister five uh and you
uh
called out i think that they're in this
shot but have been digitally erased i
found even more evidence of possibly
removed assets around peter during this
battle in the shot of peter leaping off
the statue of liberty head if you look
to the region to the right of peter
there is definitely an upward moving
smoky motion blur on the background rim
of that giant cap shield as if something
was here leaping out of frame removed
and when they had to pencil back in what
was behind it some of the motion blur
stayed also this one's a bit harder to
see but over on the left side of the
same shot a similar motion blur seems to
be distorting the tip of lady liberty's
spiky crown so yeah two things leaping
upward right before tom holland peter
parker does yeah i was not the first one
to see that lizard's head recoils
um everyone saw that lizard randomly
recoiled but once i saw that i was like
oh i bet these guys are all over the
scene but removed so i went through that
trailer and there is one the shot of tom
holland landed on the statue of liberty
head i noticed motion blur i don't think
anyone else saw these little motion
blurs but then in the movie all three of
them land in that frame just as i said
they would and it felt really cool to
get one that specific one right god what
there's a branch reality where there
weren't in it and that
that somehow is a worse reality than our
actual and then and then mephisto
reality to make me right to apologize
yeah another one that you got right we
talked about it uh earlier but it's it's
a pretty big one is the kang reveal in
loki based on what we know about the
loki series and the way avengers in game
left the mcu kang is actually an
extremely likely option for the next
major threat facing these characters i
could hold you to the fact that that
wasn't exactly it wasn't kind of the
conqueror that was in there
but i think it was
it was a king variant um but
conceptually you were you're pretty spot
on i'll say so was most of nerd culture
most people uh did get that one well
here's the deal dude i won't out who
this was but there is a colleague who uh
i very much respect they dm'd me the
week before the loki finale and said
hand to god it's not kang i know someone
who works for marvel it's not kang and
it scared the [ __ ] out of me going into
that final week and then i had to do
like an evaluation i'm like
i don't know who this person's source is
i really trust this person but
whatever it'll be mephisto all over
again i will go down with the ship of
kang and ultimately it was a kang
variant i don't know who that person's
source was maybe that they were hinting
at the fact well it's not kang it's
a king variant i don't know yeah it
might have been that um i'll also say
mostly what was important about that
time is it was the win that we needed
you know like just we didn't believe
that so
we just like the those 140 000 new
subscribers or whatever where you know
uh they just need to see something go
right yeah um another one that went
right that's very similar actually is
that kingpin would return in hawkeye
which is actually like kind of was going
to be more of a stretch than kang bean
and loki because you know we knew that
that jonathan majors had been cast uh
but kingpin was like a character that we
thought was just done for and there was
no confirmation of that evidence has
emerged hinting at how both of these
titles could be coordinating to reveal
papa feige's secret plan to reveal in
the mcu faces from the netflix marvel
world vincent d'onofrio as kingpin
wilson fisk and charlie cox as daredevil
matt murdock are we looking at a course
miracle of wilson biscuits coming to
slamming your head in a car door i feel
like at the from the trailers of the
show with with echo being part of it
with the track suit mafia based off of
the comics like kingpin felt like much
less of a risk as soon as we saw the
cufflinks as it pinched her cheek i was
like oh yeah this has got to be kingpin
uh with kang it was right up until the
end where i was like i really don't know
it's gonna be carrick or not but kingpin
i felt pretty good going into that
series that at least we would see a
version of kingpin whether or not was
dinafrio was really the mystery there
moving on to wanda vision
uh obviously you had your your mephisto
disaster um but
uh you also uh talked about how one of
the commercials um was gonna be for an
antidepressant product and that uh
that's beca you try to tie that to
doctor strange do not be surprised if
this next commercial in the modern
family era is a stereotypical
pharmaceutical ad medication for anxiety
depression or whatever hopefully
undiagnosed condition wanda has because
no one wants to accidentally
mischaracterize any of those very real
conditions even though doctor strange
didn't end up being in the show you
actually were right that he he was
supposed to be
and that those words that led to my
it was like confidence uh what's it
called go with before the fall like
when uh we had seen the first five
commercials we knew there was gonna be a
sixth one and i somehow was able to just
predict oh this show is about wanda's
mental health there's probably going to
be a commercial about antidepressants
because that's what is the most parodied
format oh wouldn't it be great if doctor
strangers are pharmacists you know and
that was they intended on doctor strange
being like he was going to cameo in that
scene and i got so drunk on power from
predicting that one right that i'm like
well then i can't be wrong about
mephisto
and so i think that led to me going so
strong on mephistobe i think it was that
same episode episode seven when i saw
agatha all along i'm like no i see
things in the show no one else does but
you sometimes do it you also were right
about uh agatha's rabbit being a demon
in disguise that's since been been
confirmed um not the demon that you
thought it was but a demon he played
baby jesus in last year's christmas
pageant the son of god played by an
animal it's a little odd dare i say
sacrilegious because that name senior
scratchy sounds like an odd to mr
scratch or old scratch which are
nicknames for the devil for people that
wonder uh how much we keep track of this
also eric throughout the year also sends
over like hey by the way i was right on
this theory or whatever and that's a
part of how we compiled this list uh and
sometimes i reject them uh
so i i i wanna i would just want to know
that he uh wants credit for um mutants
showing up technically uh in black widow
uh because ursa major um
was in in a scene um in alexis uh prison
scene no that does not count as mutants
according to the actor he accounts that
actor went on instagram and said i'm the
first mutant and then see you an actor's
instagram uh will never be a source that
uh we can use here uh also uh like like
you said earlier you thought the face
swap technically did happen uh i will
never let you do that unless i see the
peel skin and the pizza sauce face of
face off that's the only thing i don't
want to see that giving you well that's
not what we got and so then you're wrong
uh
but uh one that you were super right
about which was like so big it's so
ridiculous listen to eternals that the
celestial uh uh tiamet was like gonna
have but he was sleeping inside the
earth and he's gonna hatch and all this
and that's exactly the plot of the film
so this could be the emergence of a
celestial gestating inside the earth the
way ego used his planet as a kind of
shell in the comics there is a celestial
known as tiement the dreaming celestial
who sleeps buried in a vault underneath
the mountains on earth yeah yeah uh and
i think a lot of that was like in the
trailer we see
some brief shots of ereshim's um
universe history montage and you see
planets and uh
and suns and solar systems forming and
i'm like why would we see that in the
movie if not to show the origin of the
celestials and there was this big talk
about how chloe zhao had this big pitch
and while i was watching footage for you
know that movie and trailers i was like
well there's got to be something
interesting
to come out with yeah in order for them
to talk it up so much
uh i will still quite a
leap
i mean i got those captain america
shields dead wrong about eternals though
i really thought cap shield was going to
be in throughout history
um yeah and uh no that was just a weird
production design coincidence yeah great
thumbnail great phone man i i'm gonna
give you a beat here you don't know that
i'm planning this but i'll give you a
second here to prep i want you to go
ahead and just take one of your biggest
swings of uh 2022
right now right here something that you
think is going to happen in 2022 just
something huge take that big swing while
you think on that i want to give a shout
out to our buddy empty who had just one
of the worst theories uh
i love empties theories mg theories are
so good empty series are so fun and
they're like like so enjoyable except
this one
i did not i wanted it so badly to not be
true he was convinced
that mysterio was actually the one up to
everything in no way home the events the
characters all of them were were a
mysterious illusion which would be
amazing for mysterio and terrible for
the fans terrible for everybody else
like it's so cool for that character but
it's just like no none of this was real
i was so happy uh for my friend mt to be
wrong
all right that was a quick shout out to
mt
eric
your big 20 22
swing of the year
for now in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness not only will it
introduce mutants they are specifically
going to show us a fox x-men actor
whether that be patrick stewart is
charles xavier uh ian mckellen as eric
glensher magneto
or hugh jackman
as
wolverine will see one of them
or ryan reynolds is deadpool but i'm
going to say all four of them uh and
then and ray park is toad shake that
in addition to that wanda max mop will
will utter some variation of no more
mutants or let there be mutants some
kind of variation of that let there be
mutants now and then like dances and
like lights show up
[Music]
it's like sexy as hell
uh
how
[ __ ] dare you
after
you got so many times wrong when mutants
were gonna show up all year long even
you just contradicted yourself about how
you said they've already showed up
because of black widow you're still
making here that it is here's their big
debut
uh if you are wrong
um
someone uh let's see we'll die
yes yeah someone close to you will die
uh darling gets your job
um and uh tommy bechtold is no longer
allowed in the office that's unrelated
that was a memo that i needed to send
you no he just did something bad and i
just forgot to tell you he's no longer
allowed in the office
it's just another side great job uh this
past year you very much killed it um you
were a great quarterback uh for the team
and there were some big losses but
honestly some big wins and i feel like
at the least we got to a bowl game uh
when
uh yeah mephisto would have been the the
championship but that wraps up this year
in review uh i love doing these uh guys
brace yourselves obviously 2022 because
of multiverse of madness and everything
coming is going to be probably an even
crazier year of theories i've told eric
he can he can
loosen the belt on the theories that
he's been holding back i know you got
some uh so the return potentially some
scroll search that there's some
potential oh yeah skull searches
background
everybody's a script yeah
uh uh all year you're gonna get theories
i like this again uh remember to support
us by going to new rockstarsmerch.com uh
and also uh just chat us up on twitter
um eric is gonna promise to be much
nicer on twitter this year he's at eavos
and i'm at philip molina uh follow new
rockstars at new rockstars and subscribe
to us if you haven't already it's weird
that you watch this video and you're not
subscribed uh but yeah you're gonna get
a lot of plausible ish sounding kind of
[ __ ] theories here uh on this
youtube channel eric any any last words
uh for yourself um hold on to your butts
alright see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you